is it really worth going to college in
today's day and age with such
indoctrination like it's talked about in
brainwashed the question you should ask
yourself is not should i go to college
it's
what would i want to get out of college
if you want to get a job at goldman
sachs
good reason to go to a big name brand
school if you want to get a proper
liberal education there are a handful of
schools where you could still get that
if you want to get a mechanical
education and just learn a trade well go
do that you don't need to go to some
four year college i i don't think that
any longer
we are in a position where in order to
succeed in the world you have to have a
college degree i think that people are
waking up to the
mostly worthlessness of those degrees
they don't really mean that you're
educated anymore even from the big
schools so i i would
i as you examine all sorts of questions
in life i would ask first what is the
purpose what's the purpose of this thing
and then when you answer that question
you'll have a much clearer view on what
what college you should go to and if you
should go at all